what would you guys think is like
traditional for like Australian like
what's what's the Australian Cuisine
soul food kind of here uh chicken Palm
maybe yeah
how the hell did chicken palmy like
become a staple of Australian Cuisine I
think it's just it's really hard to hate
chicken cheese and marinara you know
it's just like that classic like Pub
feed and like that's yeah beans and
toast about us and you have just [__]
chicken trees yeah that's like well I
mean you know there's a lot of Aussies
who eat you know like beans and and
toast do you yeah I used to have that
for breakfast yeah it's a safer like
breakfast food here yeah yeah yeah like
egg or cheese on it too and now you're
getting fancy that's way too fancy
Australian the thing with Australian
Cuisine is that it's like it's three
ingredients Max yeah you know it's like
oh we we could have you know like we
could get really fancy with Avo on toast
but why not just have Avo and toast and
that's it maybe little cracks salt and
pepper maybe yeah maybe if you're
feeling fancy yeah that's crazy and
that's getting British cooking
I guess like uh like uh what's what's
the fish that we have here that
barramundi yeah barramundi yeah that's
that's like a that's like a pretty
staple like Pub feed here oh yeah yeah
it's pretty good that's pretty good I've
not tried that yeah barramundi like a
barramundi uh like burger or like even
just like you can get all sorts of like
brown money in like pubs and stuff like
that it's pretty [__] good coffee
culture here is my favorite yeah yeah
especially yeah it goes so hard yeah I
remember the first time going to America
getting coffee and be like what the [__]
is
like I met like Starbucks is this
massive conglomerate comedy I'm just
like they're just serving the worst
coffee you don't want it you don't want
to have coffee in Japan wait I thought
it was right I think Starbucks in Japan
was actually all right yeah
which is like yes anywhere outside of
Starbucks it's [__] well no this there's
something like because what is it
coffee's on the waves right so coffee's
on Wave like the wave three which is
like the season three well it's like
it's like yeah it's like it's like the
minimal coffee right yeah you go in it's
all concrete wood and then those kind of
places are normally pretty decent
because they're all espresso based and I
feel it's a gamble though because like
I've been to some like really fancy
looking coffee shops where it's like the
outside looks pristine like you you
think it's been there for like hundreds
of years and it's just like the guy's
just like professional about it all and
then you pay [__] you know 15 bucks
for a cup of coffee and I'm like this is
just dirt water like I I got really
annoyed one time because I went to one
that was kind of like similar yeah and
it was like a again it was all
minimalist concrete and they had he had
an espresso machine there and I was like
okay let's go yeah and so I asked for a
coffee and I'm like can I have a can I
have a coffee and so if
he just whips out like a pour over kit
and starts pouring over it I'm like dude
right behind me is that that machine
that's it for looks yeah yeah I'm like
dude I I thought it was going to be
espresso I wanted espresso such a first
world problem such a first world problem
but I was just like so sad I was like no
were you did you ever uh want one like
very common thing with uh anyone who
like goes to Japan for the first time
and lives there for a period is uh the
venue machine coffees were you ever on
that or
we dabbled in the boss a little bit Yeah
Yeah
boss man
I mean what was the one I really liked
the one that had like the the milk in it
um rainbow one it would not oh that one
was good too yeah
um but it was like uh it was like creamy
caramelly color on there that's crazy
how many variations yeah coffee yeah
um and a lot of them are very very sweet
yeah but like again I was in the winter
as well and it was like oh yeah coming
out hot so it's like
I do like the the stabbing ones from the
combini the cartons yeah oh yeah
non-sweetened ones or they just call it
espresso even though it has milk yeah
right yeah those are good sometimes in
the winter I would not even like drink
the coffee I would just go to a vending
machine and just buy the whole coffee
and uh and just use it as a hand warmer
yeah yeah I remember when we went
camping once uh we went camping like in
like near Mount Fuji I was [__]
freezing Chennai yeah uh and uh we
didn't have any hand warmers so what I
did is just I went to the vending
machine [__] brought like six coffees
and just like dipped my coat in like all
like like dipped uh put all the coffees
like in my car and just slept with like
a blanket of like Boss Coffee
shout out the boss yeah the boss called
me y'all made sure I didn't freeze that
night yo you got it all man you got it
all so what do you uh what do you think
is like what do you think is the future
like the next like two three years for
yourself oh that's crazy that was a good
transition yeah I went from like what's
your coffee though what were you doing
what are we doing what's the five year
plan so I reckon here's the plan right
okay I got like the next six months
that's best I give you yeah because yeah
I never was thinking six months ahead at
a time
um six months so next couple months do
some traveling enjoy life
yeah come to Japan as well yeah yeah oh
yeah Late July August so this is a
little after that but yeah we'll keep
keep it going
um yeah just gonna see a lot of my
friends overseas they got a couple bucks
Stags and weddings going on so she's
gonna enjoy that come back Studio's
ready
grind like I'm gonna hit so I've hit
like a couple hard grinds in my career
so like starting off in Minecraft like
growing
biggest grind going
um you know how they have that thing
where it's like you know you can pick
work friends and then like family or
something and it's like pick two there's
no rest it's like work family and rush I
think that one's the one too is it that
one [__] I don't know anyway well the
thing was I picked work and then I
picked work again so it doesn't matter
which is that's just YouTubers yeah
that's that's it right but that was like
yeah first four years was biggest grind
ever took a little bit of break yeah
Pokemon go came out big grind fortnite
came out massive like four year long
grind yeah yeah I've tapered off last
year
um and I'm gonna come back I'm gonna hit
one last grind
the last grind that lasts like 10 years
or something you know it's like okay
this is the last Pride season final
grind part one
Tune In Tune in Final Boss uh in your
career have have you had a point where
you're like this is the last year this
is the last grind and I'm gonna chill
well I think even this is like kind of
very bold as [__] to say this is the
last grand at the age of 28. you're
gonna grind again yeah
yeah it does sound cooler uh but I think
that's like the last grind before like
you start looking at like the more
serious what's the next 10 years looking
like well you know you got to have like
oh I don't know you don't have to right
but like in my head I would like to we
know one day have a you know a wife and
kids yeah you know I don't think you can
do that with that level of grind so I
think this is the season finale of grime
before the serious era okay
so yeah but I I feel like there's a fact
you know as as a married man here guys I
guess I guess I guess
yeah yeah I'm married do you have kids
though no I don't yes I feel like that's
the big okay that is yeah I feel like
that's the biggest right now I guess
both me and my wife are grinding yeah
love that yeah yeah yeah
um so I feel like the big turning point
is when kids come and but but like I
feel you know even though you have kids
even though you get married or something
I feel like there's a fallacy to be like
I have to like give up this part of my
life oh you know because I feel like
there is like you know there's been
YouTubers who have had kids and built
families and not made content around it
like you know like a like a toxic kind
of way you know
um so I feel like there is a way to
adjust your lifestyle to I guess grow up
a bit no definitely yeah yeah definitely
but like this level grind had done oh no
like the date the daily uploads the
[__] working every day 16 hours
that's that's gotta stop yeah yeah no
100 so yeah definitely looking to to not
do that again and even then like with
this one I'm coming back on it's like
I'm definitely looking to Outsource a
lot more of team and like trying to
build they're spending this this two
months to build that team yeah how many
people are you working with right now
between myself and power
um and contractors including like
players I'd say I think we're at like
30.
gotta make some fortnite videos yeah
yeah but that way but this is the thing
with the orgs right like there's just so
many people that yeah that's where it
comes out of and I'm like well I think
we're doing well like outside of myself
we're not profitable yet but we're like
very close when do you think you'll be
probably not bleeding money is yeah no
I'm not I hate losing money yeah me too
me too yeah how long do you think you'll
need before you get profitable I reckon
if I'm not profitable next year
that would be amazing like we're close
like I think like our investment in this
studio office is the I think if we
didn't do that I think we actually would
be profitable okay so it's like a
reinvestment okay okay so we're like
we're like we're we're close okay all
right yeah awesome yeah